if you go for the earning early you stop
the learning and the moment you stop the
learning is when you decide and you tell
the universe that I have made enough
this is enough for me I don't need to
learn anymore I am good enough and that
from some pride and so if you can humble
yourself and you realize the Dunning
Krueger effect exists that you think you
know more than you do when you start
because you don't know anything it's why
Socrates said The more I know the more I
realize I know nothing one of the
smartest wisest people in the world says
he knew nothing he wasn't being humble
there he had an accurate perception of
reality